what is a story I think
in its simplest form a story is The
Human Experience
because when people
if you notice like when people write
stories that are like oh this it's just
about magic and it's just like it's wild
things going on and it's fun and it's
funny but there's no Human Experience
there's no heartbreak there's no loss
there's no love
you know between two people or the love
of a cheeseburger whatever it is like
what The Human Experience is about loss
it's about love it's about wanting it's
about
um hope
it's about friendship it's about family
whether you're losing the family gaining
the family it's like never forget if
you're if you want to tell a story about
a spaceship if there isn't a human
aspect to the experience then you're not
really telling a story you're just
telling us about a spaceship
we need to know
who lives in it who lives in the
spaceship what their lives are about
what do they want what's their history
uh so that we know where they're going
we know what we're following
um that person's want
that desire to live The Human Experience
is the story
so
I hope that's clear but I definitely
think ultimately your stories have to
have those things it has to have love it
has to have loss not all at the same
time you can be just one of them but
some aspect of The Human Experience is
what your story needs to be about
what is character flaw and why is it so
important to creating story oh
character flaw is
the story or it is the
the journey I would say so I would say
that the character flaw is the Journey
of the story if your character doesn't
have a flaw that they need to overcome
it's going to be difficult I think as a
Storyteller to figure out the journey
that they need to go on to
overcome that flaw
so if your character
has no flaw
what exactly are we watching we're
watching
someone who wants
something
and can easily get it and nothing's
gonna stand in their way and then
nothing does and then they get it end of
story that's not a story or at least
it's not a satisfying one but if you're
watching somebody who wants something
and it's very hard for them to get it
because of who they are because of
something that is that they are
struggling with internally and then we
represent that internal struggle in the
physical world so let's say I'm a very
shy girl who really wants to sing on
American Idol
so that is my the physical
representation of my internal uh flaw
which is that I'm shy and why am I shy
because of some
um because of some like core wound where
you know maybe let's say my dad always
told me that I was uglier that I should
always like you know be in the
background my dad never did that my
dad's awesome but like whatever the
whatever the wherever the flaw is coming
from and the flaw doesn't have to be
something that is
like an obvious flaw it doesn't have to
be like oh she's flawed because she's a
birthmark like a literal flock doesn't
have to be like a literal or obvious
flaw like this person is like really
selfish it could be something that you
you know that becomes a flaw because
maybe the person loves too much or
something like that
um and they're external their external
representation of that is that they are
in a um they need to find they need to
find their partner for in a dating game
show and that's like the whole episode
of you know the whole episode of TV or
maybe it's the whole movie
um and them not being able to do it
because they they love too much but
point of matter is like your internal
flaw your flaw is
what directs you as a writer to figure
out what Journey your character is going
on because whatever the internal flaw is
you'll be able to reflect it in their
physical reality in the story
is there a character you can think of
male or female where you just you you
loved how the flaw was portrayed and it
made them more human
I'm trying to remember the name of this
movie so I think in Palm Springs
um you have in the female character a
woman who like really doesn't believe in
love and you have Andy Samberg who is
someone who just thinks that you know
nothing matters anymore because he's
been reliving the same day over and over
for God knows how long and you know in
the movie Her flaw is portrayed to be
someone who's kind of like you know it's
well-worn territory she's like cold she
doesn't believe in love she's kind of
like heartless because of
um some I don't want to ruin the movie
some bad experience that she had and
what's interesting was that the
resolution to the movie the way that
they figure their way out of the time
warp
um
it's her flaw that helps her figure out
her way out of the time warp it's her
dogged Relentless Drive
um it's how smart she is it's how
irreverent she is
um how much gumption she has so like the
things that are kind of negative about
her that like make her and Andy Samberg
butt heads is also the thing that gets
them out of the time warp
um I don't know where they end up if
they actually end up in like present
time but like the the the the the way
that they used her flaw I thought was
like really creative and really
um
true to life that things don't always
resolve perfectly and the things that we
think are not the things that we think
about ourselves that our flaws are also
our strengths sometimes
so I really love the message that movie
why is change important in the story
yeah I think
um
changes the story
I think there is no there is no story if
there's no change if there's no
realization if there's no uh resolution
like the change is what marks the end of
our story
um so it's hugely important
even with Groundhog Day or Palm Springs
there it sounds like there's little bits
of change that finally get
the characters to evolve in some way
absolutely and that's the big difference
between like a a feature film or a TV
a TV episode even it's in in a TV
episode you have 30 minutes to show a
character or characters go through some
change
in the film you have about 90 minutes to
show a character go through change
um but change nonetheless whether it's
in 90 minutes or 30 minutes so it's very
much like there if you're if there is no
change if your character doesn't undergo
some sort of change whether it's a
change in their perspective a change in
their attitude it changes something a
change in Direction
um then we really didn't end the story
didn't really resolve it
is that something that's the most I
wouldn't say contentious in the TV
writer's room but where you're you're
the writers as a group are figuring the
way out of the story or or are people
taking turns with different episodes so
that's not really an issue I mean the
writer's rooms that I've worked in have
all been extremely collaborative so you
know in order for us to write a story
together we have to be on the same page
and I wouldn't say that it's contentious
I would say that usually the beginning
is a little bit more contentious because
the premise the beginning determines the
outcome so like even in the grand crew
writers room I remember
um the we had a really big debate in the
room about
um whether or not Noah and Simone should
get married because at the end of season
one
um he proposes and I won't you know I
won't ruin it for anybody who hasn't
watched it but I love Grand Cru you
should definitely watch it but like
um we're we're the contentious part is
the beginning do they do we answer this
question how do we answer this question
is it a yes or a no because that the way
that we answer the question determines
everything it determines the end of that
episode it determines the season it
determines that the season finale so
it's just like I think the way you start
is so much more important because your
end organically comes from your
beginning